there's a creature scurrying across your
face right now yes you and at some point
maybe now maybe in a few days it's going
to find a nice cozy pore in your skin
and lay a single enormous egg meet the
face mites they're smaller than a grain
of sand are a kind of arachnid like
spiders and they feast on the oil and
cells in your skin particularly on your
oily nose cheeks and forehead
scientists suspect they've been living
on us since the dawn of humanity
over 200 thousand years ago and today
study suggests practically every adult
on the planet has thousands of them odds
are you've been living with them your
whole life babies quickly get them from
their parents a few days after birth and
once those face lights are on you the
only thing they enjoy as much a slurping
oil and nutrients from your pores is
having sex all over your face
afterwards females burrowed deep into
your pores where they lay their eggs the
eggs end up in one of two places
depending on the species a face might
the first species called demodex
folliculorum lays its eggs in your hair
follicle while the second prefers
nesting in your sebaceous glands and in
under two weeks the babies hatch meat
lay their own eggs and die leaving
behind a pile of decomposing corpses now
you can wash some of this off but you'll
never eradicate them completely because
even if you treat them with antibiotics
they'll return in about six weeks tops
you'll pick them up from towels pillows
and your loved ones well that all sounds
horrific but usually face mites are
harmless they only become a problem when
they multiply out of control this can
happen in people with an impaired immune
system it's also been seen in people
with a painful skin condition called
rosacea normally you'll have around one
or two mites per square centimeter of
skin but one study found that people
with rosacea had ten times the normal
amount believe it or not in some cases
these mites can be useful
researchers can actually study your face
mites to learn about your ancestors you
see most nights often stay within a
community so over time they've evolved
into distinct lineages in different
geographic regions and by comparing
their DNA scientists can trace how
different groups of humans migrated
across the world for example a study
found that European mites genetically
diverged from East Asian mites around
40,000 years ago that's the same time
European and East Asian humans parted
ways pretty handy so when it comes down
to bugs crawling all over you it could
be a lot worse